The general good experience for sure.
He's going to win again.
I'm going to be the president.
So you think for sure he wins again
because is that because whoever the
Democrats decide to put in,
is it going to be an equal turd?
Sandwich again,
you're a super smart dude,
but you're also a bruton.
Your big giant savage motherfucker.
Right?
So how many people have underestimated
you because you're a big giant savage
motherfucker planning talk stupid to you
and acted like you were a moron.
I'd say equal street fights.
Two fights in the UFC.
Yeah,
there's a lot of people.
Right?
And just people in general,
like they'll get snotty and take stevie
at tree.
I'm glad I'm going like my men.
But I think there's a certain part of us
that might be doing that with him.
I don't think he is.
I think he's really good at winning.
This is this,
this is not a,
not an like an endorsement of him.
Um,
no caveats necessary.
I'm horrified by this immigration policy
of separating children from their
parents.
I think that subhuman,
his wife came out and said that was
bullshit.
His wife's an immigrant bro.
His wife barely speaks English.
It's chaos,
right?
It's crazy.
I hate.
I hate all that stuff.
These are just families.
They're just.
People love each other.
You got to keep them together.
If they break the law,
you keep them together.
Get them out of here if you want.
I mean,
if you want to send them back to
wherever they came from,
if you're,
you're hell bent on that.
But taking them from their kids is
subhuman.
I mean it's beyond that.
It's not us.
It's not what we're doing in 2018.
That aside all that aside,
he's probably gonna fucking win again,
man.
I think he's probably gonna win again.
I think he.
He gets in these confrontations with
people and they think he's adult.
I don't think he's adult.
I think he's.
There's no way he can be as successful
as he bent.
I know he's had his ups and downs and
shit like that,
but like what?
He just just the way he was able to
dismantle all those guys in those
Republican debates,
we told them to fuck apart from apart.
They have no business.
They had no business doing that with
him.
They just were too emotionally tied up
in his responses.
There was so much negativity and energy.
Uh,
it was like,
it.
There's all this anxiety like a fight
where a guy's in a full panic,
you know,
you've seen it like street fights,
especially guys just go into full panic
or even just talking shit and the school
yard,
you know,
one guy's getting bullied.
Bullies got the crowd watching them and
the other guys will,
but,
but your,
your fuck you man.
He's like,
ah,
that ain't gonna work.
You know?
That's Kinda,
that's what the rest of them look like.
Ted Cruz,
that's what they all looked like.
He's just been doing this his whole
life.
He's been talking shit his whole life,
you know,
and he's got a lot of fucking
supporters.
And if the economy keeps doing good,
man,
it's gonna be a hard sell to put some
guy in there like Bernie Sanders,
you know,
all the right wing people think,
just wants to give away all your money,
give away all your money to welfare
brats.
Even the left was protecting against
that,
right?
Because there's still money left on the
left.
I should point out,
I know Jack Shit about politics.
It was very important to point out 100
percent.
I've read all of the works,
almost all of them.
And he is brilliant trainer that.
I agree with that 100 percent outside of
competition.
Let's explain it to people.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
so me.
Okay.
So let's say for instance,
let's say,
you know,
I'm a big believer in never being sore.
You should train the next day she'd wake
up feeling good.
Okay.
No.
Why?
How's that possible?
Well,
because look,
if,
if.
Okay,
that's great.
That's a good example.
Let's say,
um,
let's see your energy levels of second
about fit people by the way,
right?
If you met every human being,
every guy has never worked out before.
First,
they never called.
Is it possible to work out and not be
sore?
No problem.
You okay?
Here we go.
So let's say there's something called cr
rate of perceived exertion.
Okay?
So let's say I make you do pull ups and
let's say the maximum on a pull ups you
can do.
The maximum amount of bullet is 10.
Let's keep a nice round number at 11.
You couldn't do 11.
If I put a pointed a gun at you,
you couldn't do 11.
Should I make you do 10 pull ups on our
workout?
No.
I'm going to make you do five.
Why?
Because I'm setting you up to work the
next day.
The next day we're going to do five and
the next day we're going to do another
five and then we're gonna do six.
One six is really easy.
We're going to do seven y if you count
if the.
If you did 10 pull ups on Monday,
you're going to be sore throat.
Thursday.
Let's this really your Max.
So Thursday you've only done 10 pull ups
from Monday to Thursday.
You've only done 10 pull ups.
Me,
I've been doing five pull ups every day,
so I'm a 20 pull ups already.
Twenty five pull ups.
I have more volume than you.
Now,
if you add up at the end of the year,
who trained more,
I've trained way more than you,
so let's say I go to Jitsu practice.
I'm doing Jujitsu every single day,
three rounds,
five days a week.
That's 15 rounds.
You go in twice a week,
but you kill yourself.
You do five rounds each day you kill,
you push yourself.
Those last two rounds,
you burn yourself out.
I still did 15 year at 10.
At the end of the year I've done
countless rounds and what I may have had
so much more training than you.
So how much training can we pack in the
week?
That's the real question.
How much volume can you expose your
athlete too?
So I always tell people,
look,
energy,
sorry,
exercise can produce energy.
So let's say I'm feeling like a seven
out of 10,
10 being I'm really energized.
One,
I was like really lethargic,
feeling like I need to lay down and
seven,
I'm feeling good.
Okay.
If I get up and I do a right amount of
exercise,
the right amount,
I can feel like an eight point five
exercise can give me a tonic effect,
like drinking this coffee.
So let's say I just do some jumping
jacks.
I hit the back for a couple rounds.
I'm feeling good.
Once you get that high,
shut it down.
Don't go into the phase where your
body's beat up tight,
broken up,
don't redline the body that's only for
training camps for pe for a small period
of time.
Why?
Because you get a little bit more from
the system,
but in the long run you get less in the
long run.
You've tax the system.
So if you do that regularly,
by the time you actually get good
broken up is,
you know,
a realm of experience,
a realm of knowing that these things
give access to that's normally close to
us.
I mean,
it's kind of a trivial statement of
course.
Um,
but then you get down to questions of
how verifiable is that?
How real is that?
How,
uh,
you know,
and people get.
I don't know if the term is hung up,
but they can get baffled when you start
talking about,
you know,
the reality of say the entities you
encounter on dmt.
I mean this is,
this is some people I know are obsessed
with trying to verify the reality of the
entities that you find on dmt.
And again,
it comes down to if you experienced
them,
they're real.
If anything you experienced is real
because you've experienced it,
does it have a corresponding existence
in the external world?
Well,
you know,
what's external?
Let's eating turtle.
You know,
we,
we throw around these terms,
these,
these epistomological metaphysical terms
quite carelessly without really thinking
about it.
What does it mean when you say,
I'm in here and you're out there,
you know,
and then you take a psychedelic and you
realize that's an artificial boundary.
You know,
we're all one.
There is no separation.
It's separate in normal consciousness
though it's separated in normal
conscious.
But then what is normal conscious if not
a reflection of year,
neurochemical brain,
state.
I mean,
everything you experience is an altered
state because it's filtered into this
brain,
processed by the brain,
and the brain is a biochemical engine
that you know,
as I say,
often were made out of drug,
but it seems that our normal
consciousness is the best state to
propagate biological life and to keep
our Aes,
our whatever we've created in terms of
our community structures and
relationships and friendships and the
ability to build structures and houses
and things like that.
These,
all of these things are done best when
you're here and present.
Whereas when you're on a psychedelic
state,
I agree with you.
Well,
the way I've always described it as if
you had a meeting with God and you went
and God gave you all the answers to the
world and you,
you experienced undeniable beauty in the
most extreme form possible where you
couldn't have imagined it and then you
came back.
Whether you hallucinated it or not,
it's the exact same experience.
Exactly.
You can't put it on a scale right way
it,
like we've stretched the tape measure
and God is 47
inches across like just because,
you know what I'm saying?
Just because you can't measure it with
what we term our,
our,
you know,
our metrics for reality.
Right.
And that is exactly the thing.
Don't worry about whether it's real and
the way we would define real.
Is it good information or is it bad or
is it not?
That's the thing.
It doesn't matter where it comes from,
it's such a good information.
Then it has its own internal validity of
whether it came from some part of
yourself that is normally obscurity you
or uh,
came from the teacher or the aliens
transmitting it through.
It doesn't really matter.
It's a little wet,
but I just remember being a kid and like
my uncle like wasn't married or had
kids.
I was always like,
what's up with them?
Smart.
That guy,
it's partying.
Seems a go on the bill Maher route.
Do you burp?
But without getting me into the alarm.
Do you have a Bill Maher character?
You do?
I saw you did it.
You went to those people who didn't have
those people.
You're not okay.
You don't.
There is no god.
Okay.
Like
I know everything.
I kind of do agree with a lot of what he
says.
Yeah.
He's a smart guy that shows a weird
show.
Everybody talking over each other.